Oh.
(audience applauding)
I do that because I would see you when you were quite young.
We were in the same salon.
Yes, we were.
You picked through my hair to pick colors of blonde
because I'm a natural blonde. (laughs)
I used to love picking through your hair.
What good times.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, we should do that again sometime.
And your mom is always so nice when I see her.
And I love your dad, by the way, too.
It just makes me realize that we both grew up
in this sort of Bohemian, unorthodox,
spend months at a time in foreign lands,
Yeah. It's a wild way to grow up.
I feel like it made me, I don't know about you.
I feel like you kind of are similar in this way,
but it makes you really adaptable,
kind of a very malleable person and you can be anywhere.
I mean, that's why you are amazing on your show,
is that you can talk to anybody about anything.
You have this ability to kind of open your awareness
and your heart and your mind to people
no matter who they are
or where they're from or what they do.
So that's probably the greatest gift
that your upbringing gave you.
Well, thank you for saying that.
I think the word adaptable
is one of the most underrated words because it really is...
It leads to a much better life
for you and everyone around you.
Do you think you're adaptable?
I do.
Yeah. I think unless you put, like,
some kind of standardized test in front of me,
I'm adaptable, but not in that situation
'cause I jumped from school to school
and I was homeschooled,
and I struggled so much with homework
and you know, all of the things
that you're supposed to learn
when you're consistently in one place.
And I was, you know, living in Spain, and Budapest,
and Cincinnati, and it was all over the map,
but it made me love people and love being places.
And no matter where I am, I feel like I'm pretty much good.
I'm fine.
And I noticed in the research I was doing
that you do work very hard on yourself.
And you like therapy and since a young age,
you've been self-aware.
Can you tell me about that? 'Cause I love that.
I've been so lucky to be surrounded by people
who have encouraged me to go deeper into myself.
And I wanna just be a good person
and be as embracive of others as I can.
And so I think learning about myself and about
even the psychology of people...
Like, even during quarantine,
I got really into doing online psychology courses
'cause I never went to college
because I wasn't gonna get into college.
(laughing)
But I did these amazing courses,
and I'll probably be in therapy for the rest of my life.
It's like, you never finish learning about being a human.
It's true.
We have this one beautiful existence that we know of,
and we're here to remain students
and keep learning and improving.
Do you have a GED?
No.
Do you ever want one?
I mean, I did graduate high school,
but I'm pretty sure-
Oh!
I'm pretty sure it was like,
really, truly by the skin of my teeth.
Like, I think they were like,
"Just get her out of here.
Give her the thing, get her out of here." (laughs)
And I can't imagine you not doing what you do
because you're so good at it.
And you're-
Thank you.
Working in such a prolific, beautiful way.
And in this latest film, "Our Friend,"
you play Nicole who is a real person with cancer.
And I was watching the film last night,
and I just was marveling at your performance.
What was it like to embody this woman?
It was really kind of intense,
but not in a dark way.
And I think partly because we were filming
in the town where Nicole Teague is from
and her family lived there and her husband, Matt,
who wrote the original article that the movie's based on,
lives in the town with the girls
and they'd come around to set.
But this town, Fairhope, Alabama, was so small,
and everyone there knew what we were doing
and they knew Nicole and they,
say, in the restaurant that I went into,
they'd say, "She and Matt used to come and sit here
and she always did this.
And we remember her..."
Like, it was just very, very intense.
And this movie is dark and painful,
but it's also light and silly and funny.
And that's the kind of juxtaposition
that I find in real life.
And for this movie to come out right now is pretty intense,
but hopefully it'll help people
to feel inspired.
Well, it's beautiful and you're extraordinary in it.
And I can't wait for people to see it.
(upbeat music)